taskmaster taskmaster that was my
rejected composed song taskmaster
taskmaster that's me
flawlessly copying the tasks you just
did like a master this is called comedy
we've gone a whole week without covering
a cosmic Wonder video what the hell are
we doing we're gonna watch the day
taskmaster identity revealed Marvel
tricking us excited to check this out
possible spoiler warning in case you
didn't read the title I wanted to
mention recently we got to experience my
personal dream collab and that is with
the channel new rockstars if you guys
haven't found this out for a while
you'll see that we've done a lot of
reactions to their videos I've been a
major fan of their channel even before
we started covering any other videos
here on the real rejects we went on the
rogue Theory segment we talked about
Boba Fett ahsoka tano botan and how they
might integrate into the Mandalorian
season too and we also got a pitch our
darkest Batman story centered around
Bruce Wayne and Alfred pretty much
inspired by those recent Andy Serkis
comments honestly it was one of my
favorite collabs I was nervously excited
the entire time I really think you guys
will enjoy the hell out of it there's a
link in the description box and pin
comment I don't think you'll regret it
and I believe cosmic Wonder himself is
supposed to be going on as well now so
let's get to it
how's it going everybody gets warned
welcome back so migrate you know the
cosmic wonder where we talk about all
things Marvel and of course everything
relating to the MCU and today we have
some awesome Black Widow news that's
been a while since we've had any news
relating to Black Widow since the
release date had to be pushed back
unfortunately due to the corona virus as
sad as it is if there wasn't any virus
we would have already seen Black Widow
by now probably a couple of times at
least but to hold us off until November
today we have some awesome news about
Black Widow and taskmasters identity now
this has been a pretty big question ever
since we got the first leaked photos for
Black Widow we have not seen who's under
that mask not a single photo leaked or
regular have been taken of taskmaster
without the mask and every single scene
that we see him in in the teaser trailer
in the final trailer
he has his mask on right I haven't known
who he was until now so first things
first if you are trying to avoid any and
all spoilers for Black Widow including
not knowing who the identity of second
sir Warren you should click away if you
don't care and you want to know who he
is
let's get into it be sure to subscribe
to stay up to date on all Marvel content
and everything going on in the MCU and
so you can enter my giveaway for a
chance to win an exclusive Iron Man
Funko pop so of course as the mystery
around just who taskmaster is got bigger
and bigger and people started to ask
more questions how I'll began to do a
little bit of research and began to
theorize of just who it could be
and there were many different theories
like perhaps could be Hawkeye after all
we do same coming out of that tank like
vehicle with the bow and arrow or maybe
it's the Winter Soldier some people said
that it could have even been Tony Stark
which is absolutely far-fetched but it
was said but the most likely choice was
that it was going to be Oh T [ __ ] bindle
after all he appeared on stage at Sandy
Bay Comcast and crew and he's the only
member of the cast that we don't know
which character he's playing and Marvel
has been very secretive about who
taskmaster is but doesn't it seem a
little bit obvious well he did an
Instagram live session the other day and
basic Oh No
he came out and he said that there's
also this conspiracy that I'm taskmaster
and then one of his friends actually
replied but you are and then he said
well well you just want to get me in
trouble with Marvel don't you then
another person chimed in and said what's
up taskmaster in which he replied Oh
someone just said you shouldn't say that
Marvel is very strict with everything so
he pretty much did confirmed that he's
taskmaster although a little bit famous
trailer scenes that are edited that
aren't even really in the movie Avengers
infinity war scene with the Avengers and
the Hulk running and what kinda being
the biggest one they've done so far
point being they kind of like to trick
us and for a good reason which we truly
do enjoy so everything is not spoiled so
this seems a little too upfront but
here's the reality of everything odds
are he probably is taskmaster but
there's going to be a bigger twist to
this it's a movie about spies and
assassins got a better screen rant has
revealed that his character is going to
be Rick Mason and what man seems to be
doing here is honoring the comic book
origin of taskmaster
yep the description that we have for the
movie of Rick Mason's character is very
similar to taskmasters origin taskmaster
spent some time working for the US
government in the aftermath of Civil War
opposing The Secret Avengers well we
know that Black Widow is going to take
place right after the events of the MCU
Civil War and meanwhile Rick Mason is
described as a former shield operative
which could give him a potential link to
the White House as you can see the
origins sound pretty similar now the big
twist is most likely and again spoiler
alert if you don't want to hear this
click away now but the big twist is most
likely that Mason is going to be some
type of lover of Natasha and former
shield colleague but will go on to be
revealed to gee likes a big black big
night of the movie they'll show us
[Laughter]
I think the knees taskmaster but of
course it will be revealed at the end
that he's like this is likely what's
going to happen in fact this has been
talked about and if it's only that we've
gotten for the Black Widow film there
are definitely going to be several
twists in the movie and this is just
going to be one of them but ot seemingly
confirmed it and given the fact that his
character is pretty much unknown right
now it seems pretty obvious but let me
know what you think about this in the
comments down below when it finally
comes out it'll say er to give the video
a like and subscribe to stay up to date
on everything relating to the Harvey did
buddy live updates you can always follow
me on Twitter and as always a so much
for watching will fluff and also if you
do end up liking this video make sure to
LIKE and subscribe to our I said it
confidently confidence I mean they
brought this ot guy out on stage and
they didn't say who he was
so yeah it's obviously like it has to be
him right but I would love it if T is
not even in this movie at all and it was
just a giant mislead that Kevin Feige
setup like you're being cast to go on a
comic-con panel but you're not actually
in the movie itself that would be the
greatest thing Marvel has ever done mind
blown I would love that
I really would honestly I think it's
gonna happen at some point if you know
they use that tactic it's a great tactic
and I don't know why they haven't
implemented it yet maybe because half of
the people would be really upset about
it it begs the question where is the
line between lying and fun advertising
that's true yeah fair enough yeah I mean
I think what Black Widow the movies been
doing that's so well in its marketing I
feel like we're less interested in
uncovering black widows origin tale per
se or find out more of her backstory I
mean yeah we're curious I'm curious I'm
definitely interested but I think what
more people are generally more excited
about is actually uncovering taskmaster
uncovering the other characters as well
taskmasters been a villain that had been
one that a fans haven't wanted for such
a long time is a really popular villain
I think it's clever what Marvel has been
doing with the most part of making the
character a Miss
three that way people will go to the
theaters to check out this random
prequel of a character who's already
dead today to go well I want to learn
about these guys and I want to learn
about who taskmaster isn't all that that
sounds fun and this integration of
following the Rick Mason storyline more
loyal it lines up and makes more sense
that it was taking place after Civil War
going after The Secret Avengers all that
does sound great really my big takeaway
from the story my concern for ot5 Ben
Lee because Marvel has been pretty like
kind to Tom Holland and Mark Ruffalo for
it constantly messing up with the
spoiler department but this guy's fairly
unknown and it's his first movie and the
whole taskmaster thing is a big secret
identity thing even though there's a
credit of his name Mason and I'm gonna
be the way how Warren told the story
here made it sound like he was like a
deer with headlights caught you know
guys coated I like to it a story read to
me you might have just been having like
a bit of uh sarcastic tone to it
well that's yeah I wonder in the back of
my mind like or this could just be a
planted little moment all along and they
add somebody on hand to be like weren't
you test master just to kind of throw
everybody off yes and to create more
confusion exactly um so I guess we have
to go back and review the tape yeah make
sure I mean it can be pretty easy to
troll in a department like this too
especially if people are just chiming in
on comments and just saying something
you're having like sarcastic quips back
in four really I mean if he is it's not
a big deal if we know who taskmaster is
as much as much fun as it's been trying
to decode the mystery of it as much as I
would have liked to you know wait to go
to the theater to find out what if it's
just following the comic story no more
loyally and we can all just do a
Wikipedia search if we want it to to go
it's Rick Mason is who taskmaster is in
the comics and then we go to the movies
and you're like oh yeah it's it's Rick
Mason if you end up watching the film
yeah I could see that certainly I mean
like at the end of the day it all comes
down to how he's used in the movie the
context around it and yeah I mean to me
yeah I mean the surprise factor is I
don't know cuz we don't know for sure
but yeah
not I'm not sitting here going I feel so
slighted to know this information like
it feels like especially for the Black
Widow movie the ensemble vibe is what
I'm getting is the the core of it the
storyline idea of having them be like
past lovers does create a sense of
tension I think if this was black widows
I mean is yes is our first solo movie
probably her only solo movie but it's
her first solo outing if this was her
introduction I'd be like ah we don't
really need that generic storyline
infused in here why do we need this
whole tragic love backstory thing to
occur but you know it does create a more
personal villain in the sense I feel
like it's appropriate now after having
so many Black Widow movies and they're
never fully committed to the romantic
storyline elements that things got
dropped but Bruce Banner in other cases
she's been like sexualized so there's
flirting things happening but they have
something that's a little bit more
in-depth with a romantic storyline or
not romantic but you know heartbreak
happening I think would be cool for this
movie especially if you're doing a black
widow solo outing movie it's like yeah I
mean she's earned bit by this point
anyway I think that would actually kind
of fit because you know if the
taskmasters whole deal is he can kind of
like break down every move that you make
and duplicate it imagine how much more
sinister that is when you have like the
intimate knowledge of somebody you know
it's like they have that past experience
and that past intimacy to add to his
doir that can really hurt a black widow
in a way that's not entirely physical
you know I mean but if there's footage
of people she slept with in the time
since I haven't been together and he
sees that she's had a much better
encounter with them than with him could
he also as taskmaster replicate the
moves that he saw all the black widows
other lovers do and then bring that all
into the bedroom and that's how this
movie is passionate exchanges of love
with Tasman they have to be great
because yeah you could turn on anything
and he could absorb those actually weeks
so it could be the Love Guru I think I
think the sequel is really big times
Astor's really missing out on a lot of
opportunity I know I don't fight people
there's just certain websites he could
go I think you be the master
and at this point I got to imagine
you're fine enough at fighting go master
so guys what do you think about this
reveal is it a big deal or not subscribe
to the real rejects subscriber cosmic
Wonder to click that notification bell
make sure to check out art to lab but
new rockstars broke through your video
you'll love that video last but not
least it's time for a Tyler Hagan Niraj
Krishnan and fiction story of what if
they met John wrote this one that's
right haven't read it oh boy
you're gonna love am i playing you're
playing Tyler because you do it perfect
Tyler Hagen I do a perfect Tyler Haig
and everyone knows that
Tyler sounds like exactly this is
important lots a curiosity people
started to notice the interior library
afternoon no Raj Krishnan your
stereotypical Bollywood dreamboat stands
contemplating the independent films
available moments later an incredibly
buff gentleman Tyler Haig with tree
trunk biceps and rippling pecs steps in
holding an armful of books films and
video games
Niraj damn dude leave some for the rest
of us well don't worry this is just what
I'll be watching over dinner I should
have it all back here by tomorrow
morning our morning but how will you be
able to take him and thoughtfully absorb
all that material well it's easy my
entire home is built out of screens
Tyler looks down and notices the Niraj
is only holding a single copy of the
Wind That Shakes the barley you're not
gonna watch anything else with that well
I wasn't planning on it how did you ever
do well in the movie trivia Schmo down
I've never played well not with that
attitude no I just mean I've never
actually been on this sounds like a lot
of negativity coming from you Niraj
Krishnan well I mean things get tough
sometimes but I do my best to remain
positive and friendly not with that
attitude what attitude Tyler heck you
know people may be all on edge out in
Wisconsin where you live but here in New
York we take our time and check out one
movie at the library there's that [ __ ]
talk we talked about [ __ ] alright fine
if you're so smart then load me up enter
montage of Tyler and Niraj and all
different parts of the library Tyler
loading book after DVD after game intern
Raja's quivering arms are you sure about
this I was born really because that
actually sounds like a pretty poor way
to well not with that attitude
interior Tyler's house later that night
Niraj his eyes are held open with the
same device from a Clockwork Orange
Tyler sits next to him with a bowl of
popcorn a book a Nintendo DS's laptop
and a phone hmm good luck I think I'm
starting to get the hang of this both
men laugh is Tyler a place he knew Ming
helps to buy drugs into Niraj his eyes
you know the clamps aren't even really
that necessary I'm just happy to be
watching along with you both men's to
come doing different letters they keep
their viewing party going long into the
night yeah and that's the meeting place
of Tyler and Niraj I hope you've enjoyed
this enlightening tale what do you write
things that don't take too long to write